Les oiseaux moqueurs déchirent.
(Rires)
Vraiment.
Les oiseaux moqueurs -- les Mimus polyglottos --
sont les MCs du royaume animal.
Ils écoutent et imitent et remixent ce qu'ils aiment.
Ils assurent au micro de l'autre côté de ma fenêtre tous les matins.
Je peux les entendre chanter le bruit d'alarmes de voiture
comme s'il était celui du printemps.
Je veux dire, si vous pouvez le dire, un oiseau moqueur peut le fredonner.
Donc regardez, je vais attraper des oiseaux moqueurs.
Je vais piéger des oiseaux moqueurs dans tout le pays
et les mettre délicatement dans des bocaux comme des cocktails Molotov d'oiseaux moqueurs.
(Rires)
Ouais. Et en roulant dans un quartier,
disons, où les gens ont tout, je prendrais un oiseau moqueur que j'aurais attrapé
dans un quartier où les gens n'ont rien et je le laisserais simplement filer, vous savez.
Arrive l'oiseau, sortent les mots, "Juanito, Juanito,
viens manger mon fils!"
Oh, je vais être le Johnny Appleseed du son.
(Rires)
Traversant au hasard des rues citadines, chevauchant une Cadillac décapotable
avec une grande banquette arrière, remplie de genre 13 sacs en papier marron Walmart
pleins d'oiseaux moqueurs chargés, et je prendrais tout le monde.
(Rires)
Je prendrais le mec penaud des infos du câble disant,
"Nous serons de retour dans un moment avec plus d'informations sur la crise."
Je prendrais un crétin à l'abreuvoir demandant quelle est la marque des glaçons.
Je prendrais cette femme du lavomatique qui semble toujours savoir ce qu'est être gentil.
Je prendrais votre postier planifiant des diners.
Je prendrais la dernière fois que vous avez menti.
Je prendrais, "Chérie, donne moi juste ce putain de programme TV"
Je prendrais une seule, petite phrase avec une vraie erreur dedans,
"Ouais, je crois que je pourrais venir à l'intérieur, mais seulement une minute."
(Rires)
Je prendrais une classe ESL à Chinatown apprenant, "Il pleut, il tombe averse."
Je mettrais un oiseau moqueur dans un train de nuit juste pour prendre un vieil homme ronfler.
Je prendrais votre ex disant à quelqu'un d'autre, "Bonjour."
Je prendrais les bonjours de tout le monde.
Peu importe la manière dont vous les faites.
Aloha. Konichiwa. Shalom. Ah-Salam Alaikum.
Tout le monde veut dire TOUT le monde, tout le monde sur Terre.
Et peut être qu'aussi je construirais une cage dorée.
J'en tapisserais le fond de vieilles pages de carnet.
A l'intérieur, j'y mettrais un oiseau moqueur pour --
courte explication, j'ai des parents hippies.
(Rires)
Qu'est ce qu'un violon a à voir avec la technologie?
Où dans le monde est la direction de celui-ci?
D'un côté, des lingots d'or --
de l'autre, une planète entière.
Nous sommes à 12 milliards d'années lumières du bord.
Ceci est une estimation.
L'espace est long et sa largeur se prolongerait indéfiniment,
mais vous ne pouvez pas acheter un billet commercial pour l'espace en Amérique
parce ce que les autres pays commencent à manger comme nous, à vivre comme nous et à mourir comme nous.
Vous pourriez avoir envie de détourner le regard, parce que ceci
est un triton sur le point de régénérer son membre,
et que serrer des mains répand plus que germes que de s'embrasser.
Il y a environ 10 millions de phages par emploi.
C'est un monde très étrange dans un nanotube.
Les femmes peuvent parler, les hommes noirs faire des projets, les hommes blancs construire de solides bâtiments,
nous construisons des soleils forts.
La surface de la Terre est complètement criblée de trous,
et nous voici, en plein au milieu.
(Rires)
C'est la voix de la vie qui nous appelle à venir et apprendre.
Quand tous les petits oiseaux moqueurs s'envolent au loin,
ils font le bruit des quatre derniers jours.
Je prendrais les gourous des quartier chics, les enseignants des quartier pauvres,
les artistes fauchés et les dealers, et les prédicateurs philippins, les souffleurs de feuilles,
les barmen, les médecins plasticiens, les hooligans, les éboueurs,
vos députés locaux sous les feux des projecteurs, les mecs dans les hélicoptères en vol.
Tout le monde sera entendu.
Tout le monde aura cet unique, honnête oiseau moqueur comme témoin.
Et je m'en occupe.
Je m'en occupe jusqu'à ce que tout ça se propage,
avec des salles de chat et des imitateurs et des mères peut-être mettant leurs enfants au lit
chantant, "Chut, petit bébé, ne dit pas un mot,
attend l'homme avec l'oiseau."
(Rires)
Ouais. Et après vient les équipes des infos, et
les interviews de passants, les lettres aux éditeurs.
Tout le monde demandant, juste qui est responsable de cette citadine,
nationale cacophonie d'oiseaux moqueurs et quelqu'un finissant par avertir
le conseil municipal de Monterey, en Californie que c'est moi,
et ils m'offriraient les clés de la ville.
Des clés de la ville démesurées et plaquées or
et c'est tout ce dont j'ai besoin, parce que si j'obtiens ça, je peux déverrouiller l'air.
J'écouterais ce qu'il manque, et l'y mettrais.
Merci, TED.
(Applaudissements)
Chris Anderson: Wow.
Wow.
(Applaudissements)